thanks for the introduction
thanks to Newton for having me here
tonight I'm really excited because
tonight for the for the next hour or so
it's all going to be about the command
line right
this presentation is drenched in
commands so so why not start with the
very first slide here we we stream the
the contents of a file called title to
we pipe it to a command cows a which is
a valid command it's in the in the cows
a package and with parameter W which
which with which you can set the width
of the output we we display here a cow
so in this cow has a couple of things to
say first of all it's the title of this
talk obtaining scrubbing exploring data
at the command line secondly my name
Yahweh nelson's and third my Twitter had
my Twitter handle and of course I would
love it if you would follow him follow
me but I would love it even more if you
would would give me feedback about about
tonight's presentation you see because I
am I'm writing a book titled data signs
at the command line so that title is a
little bit sexier than tonight's talk
but what do you expected it's a cow and
and I can't I can't say everything about
about data science tonight so I had to
focus down to to obtaining scrubbing and
exploring so any questions that you have
any feedback any any cool command-line
tool that you've made yourself they're
all very much appreciated so let me give
you a quick overview of what I want to
discuss tonight first I want to give you
some motivation right I think that the
cow did a pretty good job already but I
have a couple of more reasons why I
think you should be using the command
line for data science
and especially tonight again obtaining
scrubbing and exploring data I will walk
you through the essential tools and
concepts of the command-line tools that
are available by default then we're
going to look at a real world example
that's a little bit more modern and
we'll see that the basic tools don't
quite cut it and I will introduce you to
some more modern command-line tools then
we go into various tools for exploration
exploring data then a little bit about
how you can build your own data science
toolbox something very exciting called
parallelization where you can paralyze
any existing command line tool and also
execute it on multiple servers and then
if time permits I want to talk about
workflow management because working on
the command line can be quite chaotic so
I say if time permits I mean like I said
questions also during this talk very
much appreciated so some some motivation
on why I think you should be using the
command line and also what exactly is is
data science I know there are a number
of definitions out there but it's good
to have one here right now so that we
have something to hold on to and you see
data science is awesome right and
awesome here stands of course for
obtaining scrubbing and exploring notice
steps that we're going to discuss
tonight and I'm also modeling and
interpreting data these two will of
course also be also be included in the
book that I'm writing but you know given
the time I had to focus on these on the
first three let's see and this is a
model or this has been suggested by
Hilary Mason and Chris Wiggins so to
come outline what is it exactly if you
open up terminal on your Mac OS on your
Mac you will you will see this by
default it's this this window
and over here you can you can type your
commands right on a bun - this is what
it's looked like but this is the default
look of a bun - I will talk a little bit
later on how you can or that it's a good
idea to customize this so over here we
we have the prompt you will see it as
dollar sign a lot I will leave this out
so this would be the username and this
would be the host and here we're going
to type our commands and I will show you
you know a lot of commands tonight and
the output that they generate I think
I'm outline is awesome too so the
command line even though it has been
invented like a couple of decades ago I
believe that it's still a very powerful
environment to to process data with
because it it has this so called repple
right repl which stands for greed evil
and print loop that means if you have
ever played with with our or ipython you
know you know that you can execute a
command immediately or you can execute a
command and you see the output
immediately right this is very different
from writing a program from scratch and
then first compiling it and I'm running
it debugging it it's a very different
loop and this this really allows you to
do iteratively construct you know your
pipeline your chain of commands and play
with your data there are many tools
available already by default but even
today there are a lot of tools being
created in open source projects which is
great it is automatable which is a word
everything that you do on a command line
can be automated it can be scripted so
this is very different from working with
a GUI the graphical user interface where
you have to drag and drop and navigate
through menus and click buttons yourself
this is this very manual Linux or UNIX
in general on the other hand allow you
to
made everything and I think that's a big
plus especially when you want to repeat
things right if you have lots of data to
work with and you want to apply a
certain action a lot of times then this
is a good thing now these days and a lot
of startups they make they make use of
cloud computing like Amazon Web Services
for example and when you log into one of
these service servers chances are that
you're that you're going to end up on a
command line and then you know that 500
the 500 fastest supercomputers 95% of
them are on Linux so if you ever get
your hands on one of those you better
know your command line right so before I
start I would like to say this also you
might already be familiar with one or
two programming languages or
environments to process data with write
you might be familiar with R or or
Python with pandas now I am NOT saying
that you should abandon that and do
everything with the command line instead
what I'm trying to bring across here is
that the command line can be viewed as
one overarching environment in which you
have your R your Python and a whole
bunch of other command line tools that
can work together on the command line so
some some essential tools and concepts I
won't be able to give you a complete
crash course on Linux and everything
that has to do with it so I won't be
able to or I'm not going to discuss how
to create directories or delete files or
change user permissions or anything like
that what I would like to focus on is
commands that work with data so I'm
going to walk you through a couple of
tasks that have that we data scientists
do on a daily basis
and in the meantime I will introduce you
to one of them to some of the most
important concepts on the command line
and when I when I talk about tools I I
really mean this this entire list here
it's it's an umbrella term for for the
executable a script just a one-liner
that you do on your and your command
line a shell command shell function and
even an alias and if you don't if you
don't know what this means
doesn't matter we'll we'll get to that
so it's it's really an umbrella terms
and anything that you can do on the
command line and and that you can
execute on the command line and does
stuff right and before I start walking
you through a couple of commands it's
good to keep the UNIX philosophy in mind
right and summarized it's like this it's
a following three things these command
line tools they should do one thing and
do it well this is very different from
when you when you think about very big
programs that try to do everything right
they try to very often to lock you in
and that you have to do everything in
that same I'm not going to name any
names here but the philosophy here is
that you you you use a whole bunch of
commands to accomplish exactly what you
want and because they're so small and
can work together because that is the
second part here of the philosophy is
that it's very flexible and they can
only work together if they if they can't
communicate right if they if they can
exchange the data so the universal
interface here is going to be text all
right let's say we are given a data set
and if this is a data set that contains
I believe 254 instances data points and
it specifies how much the first how much
tip has been given to a certain bill why
when some when when a party goes to
dinner or to lunch and the features here
are you know the amount of the bill the
amount of the tip the the sex whether he
or she was a smoker what day it was on
time this is either dinner or lunch and
the size of the party right so this is
as raw as it gets when you when you want
to view the contents of a file you can
use cat which stands for a concatenate
but what if you don't remember exactly
what what cat means what it does I mean
immediately going to introduce you to
this command it's it's man which stands
for manual and this is the one one of
the most important important commands
you should remember because this will
always give you an overview of which
first of all what a certain command does
and secondly what kind of arguments it
accepts so just keep in mind that that
you know Stack Overflow is not the only
source where you can get some
information man is a very convenient way
and and I use it I use it daily because
some commands did they just have
parameters they well you forget it every
once in awhile so keep this in mind and
this is only a small part of it it
actually gives you a nice well at this
crawlable interface you can search
through it so that's that's good to keep
in mind right so text cat get gave a
very raw view of her data and that very
not a line very wasn't pretty to look at
so what we can do here is we can pipe
and this is a very important concept
here on the command line we can pipe
this the output of this command C so
this is an argument tips that CSV is the
file name of our data set and cat
produces output on to something
standard onto something called standard
output and by default it will be will be
output it to our screen right that is
that is the default behavior here but
what we can do is we can actually chain
two commands together by means of a pipe
that means we we pipe the output of this
command into this command which is CSV
Luke and I I said in the beginning that
all these tools would be available by
the default and I lied
there is one package that I read that I
really wanted to include here and that
is a CSV kit which is which contains a
collection of commands that are really
useful for processing CSV data because
that is a very common data format these
days together with JSON we'll be looking
at that shortly so I might as well
introduce it right here so I mean the
output here of CSV look there's nothing
standing here so again it will be
outputted to the screen and as you can
see CSV Luke is here too nicely format
our data set here and I believe it is in
pip pip install CSV kit I will give a
list of references at the end also if
you go if your you know I see a couple
of people here on their laptops and
that's that's wonderful no judgments no
judgments so if you go to my website I
think that we have some problem here
with the mic I don't know if there's
anything I can do otherwise I'll just
keep on talking stand over here alright
it actually is yeah if you go to my
website there is this blog post called 7
command-line tools for data science CSP
kit is one of those and it also gives
you a link there so zzp look here up
puts it our data set nicely so let's
let's do something with
this dataset right because we're data
scientists and we need to we need to get
our hands dirty
so looking at files we've already been
looking at it using cat boat what cat
does it just outputs all the entire file
to your screen and if you have no big
data then it's gonna be a gonna be a
mess it's gonna be you're gonna have an
information overload you know on your
screen and it's it's very unconvenient
words for small files but what you
really want to do is pipe this to a
command called less which will give you
just like man the man actually makes use
of less is give you a a scrollable
output it will just it's paginated so to
speak so you can just go to the next
page of your output scroll up and down
to other commands that are very very
often used to just peek at your data set
our head and tail and by default that
will show you the ten first lines and
ten last lines respectively but you can
set the parameter - and here - to
specify the number of lines that you
want now this this command is also
really useful to use in a longer
pipeline where you have a lot of
commands chained together and you just
you're in this debugging mode right you
want to make sure whether the commands
your you're using are doing the right
thing then it's always good to use
something like head that will that will
reduce the number of lines to minimum so
that you can say that the the iteration
becomes shorter you can play with your
data more easily question I'm sorry
yeah so the question was do you need to
pipe something into head or does head
accept a file by itself that's a good
question and the answer is that head
does accept the file on itself so
instead of cat we could have typed well
had - on three tips dot CSV right so
even here cat is it's kind of useless so
and it's it's it's a benefit you know an
ongoing joke in the in the Linux
community that there is this thing
called the useless use of cat award and
I I well I'm a good candidate for that
award here but you know it doesn't
really matter it just spins up response
one extra process and really this whole
this whole working with the command line
is kind of iterative right you you work
from left or right so what do you do you
start with cat then you wait it's a bit
too much data you you press up you you
pipe you type you know the pipe and then
head and this is how you generally go
about so but the question was a good
question in that most unix commands also
accept the filename by themselves if no
file name has been given they will in
general read from from standard input
okay let's have a look here at tale last
three lines now see as people get gets
the that's a - h-parameter meaning you
have to notice but don't output output a
header we of course lose our header
because we're not outputting the first
row of our tips that CSV data set now
sees via Luke does not have a man page
but if you specify the - smaller age
then you will get a some sort of a help
on how to use this command that this is
also very very common for a Linux
command so especially the older commands
will have an
and page and newer commands will
hopefully provide you some help when you
do either - h or - - help
excuse me o - n is the number oh yes or
a very good question what is the last
less than right over here
well I told you about the useless use of
cat award is that as here is I'm no
longer a Canada here anymore because
what we're doing here is how do we
explain this we're directly well just
piping the the output of tips that CSV
into into tail
so we're saying to tail like hey you
should be reading from this file so it
looks kind of awkward you will more
often see its counterpart greater than
where we actually output the command
where we where we write the output to a
command but I mean you will have the
same same effect so one thing to to also
note is that those pipes they are
streaming it's not like Linux will first
execute the first command and wait for
it to be finished and then output
everything to the second command no this
is this is streamed so it's very fast
and it's even and it even makes use of
multiple cores so well that's great hey
second task is filtering lines let's say
we only want to look at those instances
which were those tips that were given
during lunch time and we can use grep
and we specify first of all first of all
the the pattern or the word that that we
that we're looking for and as you can
see here we're directly giving tips that
CSV is as an argument to grab we could
have also cat it that file into grab so
I will I will do this interchangeably
just so you know you will have the same
result and then again pipe it into CSV
look so we're being returned here and
it's it's more than I can put here in
the screen but we're being returned all
the lines which just contain the word
lunch now let this method is not optimal
it works in this case but let's say that
we would also include the name of the
person giving the tip and this name
would include lunch then this line and
even though he would be giving the tip
at dinner time he would still be
included here because grep doesn't
really care where and in this case where
lunch appears on the line is just that
if it contains lunch then I will I will
output it so here's another command call
all and it does nuts that stand for
awkward but sometimes its syntax is kind
of awkward it's cause is it's kind of a
programming language on its own and when
I personally use it I always have to
look up on how to how to do things with
it I actually looked up how do I again
use a regular expression because that is
what you will see here how do I use a
regular expression just on one
particular column using awk
so what's going on here in this case
we're showing all lines of which the
party size which was greater than four
or to be exact we are actually deleting
those lines which contain of which the
seventh column which is size where we're
discarding the line if it contains one
two three or four so this is a regular
expression
here I don't have time to go into that
but it can be very powerful in certain
times so if we were to use grep in this
case there are ways to work around it
but but you would also then well these
these two first these first two columns
here would also now they would mess up
our results so awk again it's a very
powerful tool and it can be with a lot
but I always find myself using using
Stack Overflow all right so again
another tool that is that's that's in
the CSV kit package another CSV crap and
CSV crap allows you to do crap but then
on a certain column which is great
and because it uses the header
information we can that we can actually
specify which column we want to look at
by by giving the name using - C so we we
want to achieve the same thing as we did
last time right we only want to want to
output those instances of which the
party size was 5 or 6 or larger size is
the column we're looking at and the
regular expression here it's it's the
same as here with with awk right 1 2 4
in in brackets and - I actually means
inverted so do not output if if this
line if this column matches this pattern
so those are 3 ways to filter lines and
you will see you will notice that there
are always multiple ways to achieve the
same thing expecting certain columns is
very often well the thing that we like
to do there might be too much data maybe
rolls only interested in the numerical
data in our data set so we want to
extract certain columns and oh yeah what
we do in the first line is is actually
the same as what we did before but now
we're outputting it to a different
file so here you see this symbol over
here basically says redirect the output
from this command redirected to a file
called size five six dot CSV right you
can you can chain them together oh you
can create a chain as long as you want
but sometimes it's good to just create
temporary files yeah so conceptually
nothing
and I don't even know what's going on
under the hood it's just that pipes you
would use for for commands and
redirecting so using using a larger than
sign is used when you want to output two
files it's just a convention I guess you
would then instruct you know the shell
which is which is bash I haven't
mentioned this but I'm assuming Bash
here as our shell knows that you
actually want to create a file and not
that there is there is some command
called size five six dot CSV if this
file does not exist yet it will be
created if it already existed will be
overwritten and well to be complete if
you would use two of those larger than
science you would append the output to
that file if it already exists so okay
so now we have this file size five six
and we use it in on the second line with
cut and cut cut allows us to to extract
certain columns or certain characters
from each line right first we we
specified at the delimiter that we want
to use here is a comma that's with the
dash D argument and then we specify that
we want to have columns one and two
alright very simple this is a very small
command and it you know it does what it
does and
again here we're not piping it through
CSV loop just to remind you that this is
what the raw data looks like again we
can use arc for this right we have to
specify again that the delimiter is is a
comma here the field separator using -
capital F now and then we want to output
every line but then only the first and
the two columns and an arc every column
will is assigned a variable and it
starts with one and two and goes up to
seven in our case and there is of course
again a command from from CSV kit and
that is in this case CSV cut and we just
have to specify the column names this is
very very readable right you you know
what's going on and you you want to
extract the columns Bill and tip now the
advantage of this is of course whenever
your your output is for your data set is
whenever you the columns are no longer
in this and the same order CSV cut we'll
know how to deal with that because you
specify the header information and it
uses that or as with the other commands
you would have to change your command
so this makes it a little more a bit
more readable and a bit more robust but
again you would have to download CSV get
separately so it's it is good to know to
cut command separately
alright let's go work with a slightly
different data set here what we're doing
is using curl we're downloading
something from the internet and here at
this location we have a free ebook in
text version in sorry just as plain text
from Project Gutenberg which is a very
ambitious project and it scans and makes
freely available all these books as
ebooks in various formats and we're
going to use just the text format we're
gonna download with that using curl the
- s is just to say to curl that it needs
to shut up and we're gonna pipe this to
a command called T now please be aware
here that this command here is as
nothing to do with our command line this
is just like like this dollar sign here
this is the our prompt but but in this
case it's continuation prom so it has
nothing to do with it this regard it is
just there to indicate that we're still
working on our command line but it
doesn't fit on one line
so we're piping this to a command called
T now it it works together with the the
analogy of pipes where you know here
we're suddenly inserting a teep piece
and what it does is it outputs the input
it gets to a file here called fin you
know from Huckleberry Finn because
that's the book here but it also outputs
what it gets from the input well you can
also use it to as input for your for
your following commands so it's there
it's really useful if you want to save
intermediate results if you if you want
to save it but also want to continue
with it or if you have T on the end to
save it to a file but also output it to
the screen so you know what's going on
so we pipe that to to grab and what we
do
with this regular expression is
extracting all the words and the the
over ammeter here makes sure that
everything that matches our pattern will
be put on a separate line as you can see
here from the output and the capital e
is just to instruct crap that we're
doing that we're dealing here with with
a regular expression and that it has to
parse this and not treat this as a
little pattern and again we we pipe that
into T get saved as words but we also
see it here on our screen and this is a
very very long list of words of course
WC which stands for word count and it
can be used to count words but it can
also count lines and characters so so if
you apply that to a certain file you
will see first the number of of lines
then the number of words and then the
number of characters if you just want to
have the number of lines which is very
often used you would use dash L as the
parameter to WC okay what are we doing
here oh yeah I was interested here I
don't know I saw on LinkedIn I don't
know it was if you're intelligent
quickly you say a word that starts with
an A and ends with an E in 15 seconds
okay I thought why should I come up with
this I can use the command line for this
in 15 seconds so what we're doing here
is it's probably not the most efficient
command line but it was very intuitive
for me to do this so let me walk you
through the command line here so we're
using words right as you can remember
here this is this file is words it's a
very long file and every every line
contains just one word
so for each line we're going to check if
it starts with an 80 that this this half
here says beginning of the line so
that's the first thing so and everything
else everything that nothing matches
this pattern is discarded so the output
of that is then piped again to another
grab command but then we want to make
sure that
the line ends with E and I noticed now
that I'm not even taking into account
uppercase words in this case but anyway
you get the idea so and this probably I
don't know if this could have been
combined it can but this this you know
for me at this at that point that was
the most intuitive way to go about and
was faster than otherwise I would have
to go back into the main page you know
regular expressions you know so the
output of this is just a very long list
of of words that start with an A and
with an EE and there are lots of
duplicates in here and what we're
interested in in the air as you can see
here we want to get the first of all the
unique number of words and then also how
often they appear in the text so we want
to use unique which returns only unique
instance you need lines but it requires
that the input is sorted so we have to
sort everything first alphabetically
then we come we call unique and if you
specify the - C parameter it will also
give you the number of occurrences of
each word now and then and then we're
all done we're finished we use sort
again - but this time on numerical
values you see this column here will be
used by sorts in reverse order so - RN
and I know if you've never seen before
it's like what is this I'll just cook up
some Python script to do this come on
but actually it's it's used that this
particular construct is is used a lot
and you'll get used to it and you know
you guys are not now seeing I the unique
or the the output of each individual
command but like I said this is a very
iterative process so it would be much
easier to come up with this yourself
when you're doing this and of course if
you are more comfortable
working with Python or are by all means
do so I I believe that you should be
using the tool that is most appropriate
for for your for your task so what I
very often do once once I have obtained
and you know scrubbed and explored my
data I very often drop into ipython or
ipython notebook there's it's perfectly
fine replacing data another very common
task so we we have also a file called
fitness you may remember this is just
this is the sorry we use T here to to
store the out this this file here we
used T to store it into a file called
thin this is just the text as it is on
Project Gutenberg so that's what we're
gonna do now we want to make every word
uppercase so yeah definitely here is
just saying you know do not output it to
screen just throw it away and well you
can't forget that but I didn't want to
show it up in this slide this here does
all the same it's a little bit more
complex but it also supports unicode
characters so not just ASCII as the
first command right we can also you said
here we want to replay we're replacing
all the spaces with with underscores and
said a knock are often used or called
together they both have their uses and
again set is a little bit simpler than
talk very much you know replacing data
or outputting again just certain lines
that match a certain pattern and in
practice well personally I still have to
look up very often what I'm doing so
except for this one here this one this
tells like I want to substitute
everything that comes in these two
slashes with everything was between
those two and then I want to apply
globally so that's all this is again a
very common path
what you want to replace one word with
me out there
summing values so now we're already
getting a little bit more into exploring
but this is what you see here the top
command it's we use here paste so the
paste command so first we're going to
remove the header using tail it's a
little bit weird but you know using plus
two we're saying I'll put everything but
the first line it is yeah
you just have to practice a lot with
this I it's it's the command line you
know it's old so then we're saying you
know we won't only want the first column
remember you know we're specifying the
commented Eliminator first column first
field actually and then we're going to
pipe that into paste which what it does
here these are all our individual values
that we're first on separate lines while
Bosch has is to specify that you want
everything just concatenated or you know
as one line but then you should use this
as the limit as the you know it's the
character to use in between each line so
we basically have a very long equation
which we can then pipe into PC which is
it's basically a calculator on the
command line you can pipe equations to
it and what it does now what we get here
is the total number of bills or all the
amounts of bills in our data set sum
together what we can of course also use
our it is this is not so strange here
we're basically this is almost like a
loop where you say for each line
increment the variable sum with the
value that we're seeing here in the
first column and then when you're done
doing that print the sum that we have
here all right I and what do we have
here anyone recognizes this oh yeah that
that's how I hope you guys can see it
this is uh this is our right we're using
here are from the command line
Wow I'll get to that later it's pretty
exciting but you can see here we can use
our we can pipe data into our using you
know a very very simple bash script that
I wrote a while ago called Rio we our
input output and you can just you know
do our stuff with it but we'll get to
that later again as you can see three
times the same output Wow so that was
quite a ride quite a lot of tools we've
looked at essential tools tools that you
should know because there they always
will be available except for CSV kit
then so whenever you find yourself on
some some foreign computer you can which
has Linux you can trust that these tools
will be there was there a question
all right so I believe you said that I
forgot to mention that the command line
was written in assembly NC yeah a lot of
the older tools thank you very much
a lot of the oil tools that were indeed
ANSI and and well yeah and then
apparently also assembly I mean they've
been they've been around for a very long
time so they're highly optimized a good
thing is that the command line or
actually your shell which executes the
command doesn't really care about what
language you you've used so you can use
everything all your existing code and
we're going to look at that you can use
your existing code and make them part of
the command line so that you can tie
them together with everything else that
is out there question
okay so the question is here is there an
equivalent for CSV kit for PDF files and
well III know that there are quite some
packages out there that allow you to
extract text from PDF it's not easy
because PDF is apparently well it's it's
quite an annoying format to work with
I'm sure you have already experienced
that but well I'm not I don't know if
they're also available on the command
line but I do know I mean a lot of
people have to deal with with PDF files
so I'm sure there will be software for
this but yeah you would just have to do
a Google query for this Oh or I'll do it
afterwards all right
okay great thank you very much so I hear
now that the C's V kid has been inspired
by a PDF T K which is a whole suite of
tools working with PDF thank you
yeah
yeah so the question is here is there
something equivalent to our studio where
you have on one side I've never worked
with our studio I always use our from
the command line but I believe then that
you would have on one side on your
screen your script and on the other side
well the the are console yeah so so you
you everything you've seen so far you
can also just put it in a file and then
execute it that's that's actually going
to be I'm going to be talking about that
so definitely there's not a full-fledged
GUI but you can use any editor that you
like I I can recommend either vim or
Emacs if you want to be productive to
create your scripts okay all right so
we've seen a lot of commands and I don't
blame you if you have you've already
forgotten like 90% of them I mean but my
time in time and with a lot of practice
you will just remember all these small
little command-line tools and it takes
practice there is a learning curve but
it's it's definitely worth so let's have
a look at something that's a little bit
more modern more modern tasks web
scraping and we'll see that these these
these old tools or these the tools that
I've just shown you don't just don't
quite cut it and we're gonna use some
more modern tools to work with our data
so let's let's let's imagine that we
have here that we have a website that
contains data right that is there is a
data set but it's embedded in HTML it's
horrible but if unfortunately there is
still a lot of data embedded in an HTML
markup and that's well well we can we
can we can handle that right so we have
here a Wikipedia page Wikipedia page
with a list of countries or territories
and
and well their border area ratio so we
want to extract this this table right so
that we can work with it just like we
could with our first dataset tip dot CSV
so let's do that
curl you've seen this command before we
it allows us to download any file from
the internet and it will output you
can't see the full URL but you will you
later you'll see you later
it will output it to to the screen by
default but let's assume that we have
stored that into a file called wiki de
HTML so you see here it's horrible
there's nothing really we can we can do
with this just just applying grab or awk
on this it's it may work but you know
it's doesn't give a good presentation so
let me introduce you to some other to
some other tools we're gonna we're gonna
use the HTML file here and we're gonna
pipe it through a command called scrape
which is a tool that I wrote in Python
and all it does it it extracts certain
HTML elements that that match a certain
CSS or XPath if you're interested CSS
selector so if you if you recognize or
if you if you know CSS that you may
recognize your a table that wiki table
so we have a table the table element
which has the class wiki table and what
we don't want is all the children that
are of the element TR row that are rows
except for the first row so this is just
basic CSS you can use the exact same
formula right here to style your your
HTML so in order to obtain this the CSS
selector you would have to go into the
source or use use your favorite browser
developer tools your did this this sign
here is just to indicate that we're
continuing on the next line and here
again we have to
greater than sign and it doesn't really
have to do anything with with the
command so the output of this command is
well here it really starts again it's
it's it's TR the this row actually
corresponds or you know this this text
here it is HTML corresponds to this
first row right so it works
I checked it before but here you know -
B what it does it it also gives it also
encapsulate all our TRS all our rows
into a body and an HTML tag so that the
next command is able to work with it and
that's XML to JSON so HTML as you know
is it as a form of XML and the tool XML
to JSON well as the name implies
converts xml data to json data and well
the output is here on this page JQ is a
very interesting command we're now here
just using it to display our our data in
a nicer and prettier way so you can here
again see the same the same elements we
have HTML body TR and it's all it's it's
deeply nested but then here Vatican City
so you know it again corresponds to the
HTML that that we had and that
corresponds to the table on a Wikipedia
page but JQ it's it's a relative new
tool and if you work with JSON data I
can really recommend it it's it's a
wonderful egg grep for JSON and so what
you see here is we give it we give one
parameter which is sort of an expression
given to JQ and how to transform the
JSON data that we have into a different
format basically all that we do is we're
specifying for new variables in our in
our in our JSON dictionary per row
namely comes
border surface and ratio and what we're
done saying it should have the values of
these T DS TDS are are the cells in our
rows and we're just we can index them
with one two three and four it's it's a
bit cumbersome but it really as you can
see now or we really have that table
into into a structured format that we
can work with now last but not least
there is a command JSON to to CSV which
also as its name implies converse JSON
data to CSV data and you might think
like this is insane so many so many
commands to just obtain this kind of
data to get to this result and I agree
but what you have to keep in mind is
that it is an iterative process and
because these these tools are so small
can all work together it makes them
really flexible in all ways you can
always in some way achieve your goals
here so at last we have now obtained a
data set where we have just the border
and the surface and we print this again
we using CSV look and if you combine
that all this is this is the total
command so so again we we download the
entire HTML typed it in to scrape using
this CSS selector we're able to only
output those HTML elements which are
matched using this this CSS selector we
packed it into XML to JSON so XML is
converted to JSON Jake you can handle
JSON so that's great and using this
beauty over here were able to to
transform the JSON data that we
originally got which was deeply nested
and there was a lot of structure in
there that we don't really need into
something we could work with and then
finally JSON to CSV you know we're
actually only interested in these two
fields border and surface alright so so
that was
quite a journey and this is this is this
is usually how it goes right it again it
all depends on what you're most
comfortable with
so just you know in yourself try to
think about how you would accomplish the
same using your favorite programming
language or where would you make the
switch would you would you use requests
in the little request library and and
Python to download the file or would you
rather have
I don't know JSON loads in Python to
load in the JSON so so this is very
flexible and again whatever works right
sometimes I even use pen and paper so
exploration let me quickly check how
we're doing on time I forgot how what
time we started I would say I still have
some time you'll you still see me seem
interested in this so let me continue
with exploration so anymore that's great
thanks exploration ooh look at this this
is new plot which is a very old tool or
maybe still in development
oops don't call me that butter but it's
it's indeed yes you can use it from the
command line
and we have here a scatterplot of our of
our dataset I don't even remember which
data set this one's it might even be
what we had previously we with border
and surface yes so a very ugly looking
scatterplot we can do much better than
this as you'll see I just wanted to
throw it in here some statistics first
then and we'll get to some plots later
some statistics we have here again our
tips dataset we remove the header using
tail and we only extract the second
column this time using cut and we pipe
that into cue stats which is a command
line tool developed here by
welcome by Tony he is actually in the
audience here tonight we'll get to that
later we're get to we'll get to
contributions later but what Q says does
for us is it computes a couple of
statistics for us the minimum value at a
maximum and the mean and so forth and if
you just want to mean you can specify
the - M parameter here - Q stats outside
like to highlight the histogram dot PI
function created by bitly or someone at
bitly part of their do we have anyone
from bitly tonight yes all right great
no so they have they have a repo on
github called data hacks and you just
well again you have to install it
yourself but once you have that you can
use it from the command line and we have
here histogram that PI which nicely
upwards histogram for us it doesn't fit
fit entirely on the screen but this is
just you know as you're first exploring
your data set so previously we've just
been you know obtaining and scrubbing
our data and now we're ready to really
to really get a feel for for our data
and this is usually the moment where
people try to say okay now I'm really
going into our or pandas and create some
plots using using GG plot in R or GG
plot in Python because that is you know
a recent project by Y hat you can
actually use GG plot now from Python but
support and it's just fantastic because
then you don't have to use matplotlib
anymore anyway I'm digressing so you've
already seen a little bit of this but we
can actually use our from the command
line I've created a very simple bash
script you know very simple shell script
that all it does it creates a temporary
file if you're interested
creates a temporary file that our will
read in and it will create a data frame
of this of the CSV file call DF and then
if you also specify - s here so - there
these two arguments are now combined you
can very often do it on the command line
if you have multiple arguments you know
those short arguments you can you can
put them together so it loads in the SQL
DF package which some of you may know
from our and allows us to do SQL queries
on data frames and here actually SQL on
the command line what are we seeing here
we're seeing the number of dinners and
the number of lunches in our data set
and it's all pretty fast so it really
allows you to to make are part of your
pipeline if you really if you don't
really want to go into R and stay there
but just make it part of your pipeline
you know maybe you want to use this
output for something else then this is
great it's a very happy script but it
actually works and again now there are
references in the end and how if you
want to use this and there will be links
in the end you can even use oh yes again
just using pure command-line tools that
are that are included with Linux we can
obtain the same result
oh wait I'm actually using CSV cut here
but of course we could obtain the same
with just extract the time which
contains dinner lunches expect the time
column remove the header sort at unique
C again you you you recognize here the
this this pattern here we could have
also sorted this well it's already
sorted here but it's a pattern here and
now we can even use GG blah here because
if we specify the - G parameter GG blah
will be loaded into our and a GG plot
object called G will be set up with
the data frame as its as its data and
then we can continue I don't know how
many of you have worked with ggplot
before it's a it's a it's a wonderful
library very concise way to plot things
but you can here now actually use it
from the command line and it will output
PNG so you do have to specify some you
do have to either redirect it to a file
a PNG file or use the display command
which is part of image magic in any case
when I run this a pop-up will appear a
window will appear with this plot so all
very fast and no plots from the command
line question so I want to have an on to
talk about creating your own data
science toolbox because just just using
you know the standard tools given to you
well they're always available but and
this the same holds for if you remember
those two screenshots from the terminal
on Mac and terminal and go into there
just using those standard settings you
know it's it's not very efficient it's
like it's like walking into someone
else's kitchen or brand new kitchen and
that the pots and pans are in the wrong
location and there's only one knife that
you can use so what you have to do you
may already be doing this you know using
our Python it's creating your own
collection of functions or scripts so
you're slowly building up your own data
science toolbox and as you do this you
will notice that you will become more
more productive more efficient data data
scientist so a couple of things here is
that I want to talk about now is
optimizing your environment also how can
you turn those those one-liners that
you've seen how can you turn them into
reusable scripts also how can you turn
your existing code you know your Python
your Giulia your go whatever into
command-line tools so that you can use
them alongside other tools that you can
easily share them with others so there
are a number of things you can optimize
by your environment right there is the
terminal which is actually the
application you are typing into I use a
terminal here well it's it's not the
standard terminal it's a terminal that
accepts unicode characters so if you're
working with with foreign languages this
is very useful then there is the shell
I've now assumed here bash but there are
lots of different shells available which
all have you know a little which are all
a little bit different when it comes to
you know - syntax so piping and
redirecting those are all things
interpreted by the shell and the prompt
you've seen a lot of a lot of dollar
signs so far but this is this is my own
prompt right here this is a this whole
line here let me walk you through it and
this is the place again where we can
type yours the dollar sign is the place
where we can type commands but it shows
my username the host on which I am this
is my macbook air my current working
directory which is why planned that's
that's where I were there is a virtual
environment called Y plan and I'm also
in a again repository on the master
branch and I've made changes wow that's
that's a lot of information but it's
also information you want to have handy
if you're if you're working on these
projects you don't want to well it's
it's good to know because it determines
your context and what you can do and
cannot do so and then there are of
course the aliases functional scripts
and shortcuts all right aliases these
aliases I
well I found them online on Chris
Wiggins has github profile he has a he
has a repo dare with with a bunch of
aliases and in a interview with Kathy
O'Neil he revealed that he has over a
thousand aliases and over a hundred
shell scripts that he has created over
the past years and some of them are
indeed very productive they look alike
what what I have for example L here the
top alias is alias turn this gets
translated by the shell so before this
gets executed the shell just replaces
the L with whatever is here in between
quotes and this is the LS tool which
shows you a list of files and then there
are a whole bunch of parameters here
that apparently Chris Wiggins wants to
have activated all the time so there are
a couple of others apparently it's also
really useful when you make a lot of
spelling or typing mistakes so who would
be aliased to up and so forth and I
really think that the last dude are
really funny you can show you can see
that he had an alien's I don't know if
he put this in here on purpose but you
know previously when he would type the
command onion he would go to the onion
you know at the website but now so he
comment that that out and now when you
typed onion his his shell will politely
reply with back to work so I thought it
was pretty funny I mean we all have to
find ways to stay off hacker news and
other websites as much as possible
because we need to get stuff done
all right I'm digressing shortcuts so
it's very very easy to navigate around
your filesystem in a graphical way right
you just you can always keep a good
overview of where you are
you can you can set up shortcuts you
know there as well and your desktop if
you quickly need to go to some deep
directory but it turns out that you can
also do this on the command line imagine
that we have some very deep often used
directory as you can see here we can we
can create a shortcut using the mark
function and call it deep so whenever we
want to go back to deep we just do jump
deep and we're back into that original
directory now this is actually these are
four functions that I wrote a while ago
you can also find them on my website but
if you use the she'd disease shell which
is an alternative to bash they're
actually included now in the jump
package so this has made me and a couple
of others a lot more productive and all
it took well yeah this might seem like a
lot but it's it's really not I don't
have time to go through it all but just
these four functions have saved me so
much time and this is just an example of
how you can really create your own data
science toolbox and again if you really
have something you know that makes you
more productive you think you know what
this might be of use for others as well
but all means share it so like I said
you've seen a lot of one-liners that you
type in on the command line but very
often you want to you want to reuse them
it may seem that a lot of our tasks are
one-off tasks but really when you think
about it and especially when it comes to
obtaining and scrubbing and exploring
data there are a lot of commands that we
use over and over again and as you as
you practice as you spend more time in a
command line you will learn how to
detect these patterns and if you have
detected one you can actually just copy
and paste this command and put it into a
file and then you can execute it after
if you you've done a couple of things so
first of all you would have to say to
the shell like
what what kind of script is this here so
this is determined by the first line
here this is called these two characters
here are is the the hash-bang or a
shebang
that's what they're called we're very
imaginative here these are these
actually represent for those who are
interested this is actually a human
readable representation of magic numbers
so that the colonel knows that this is
executable alright so what you say here
is that Bash should execute whatever is
in this file and bash as you may
remember is is the shell that we've been
using all along so we can just copy
paste the commands into this file and
then execute it you do have to need you
do need to to give it the correct
permissions so that you are allowed to
execute it this is what the commander
mod + X and then the file name and then
you're able to execute it and remember
the beast right this was this was a
specific this this was a very specific
command right everything was hard-coded
sometimes you want to use variables and
you can use these as well in your bash
scripts with dollar sign 1 which is the
first parameter you would give to your
file to your command and dollar sign 2
and so forth dollar sign at sign is well
we'll get to that but you will use
everything specified there and exit
codes are way to to save it the shell
like okay how did we do did every thing
go as expected and if zero is returned
and everything went normal if it's if
it's not zero something went wrong and
you can actually use this in your
pipeline to to embed some sort of logic
in there into your pipeline now the
extension is not important so let's say
you have some Python scripts lying
around because you specify using the
shebang that Python should execute this
this code it's actually preferred not to
give
an extension to this file so dot PI or
dot capital R you can just leave it away
all right and so it is very useful if
you would add to your path this is this
is a varial this is a collection of
directories known to to your shell to
bash where to look for these commands so
let's say you would have in your home
directory a directory called bin and in
there you just put all your tools
together and if you just one time you
have to specify this directory to your
path then wherever you are in your file
system you can use these commands just
as you can with the other command-line
tools so that's something you only have
to do once let me give you an example
here we have a website called explain
shell I think it's very it's it's very
nice to know in general especially if
you're learning the command line to
notice this website explain shell calm
because what you can do is you can give
it exactly the command that you want to
execute and what it does it gives you a
step-by-step explanation of what's going
on like what does each parameter mean
you don't have to sift through these man
pages yourself it will give you exactly
here we've specified at our command
which can be used to extract and
compress files x zv f first one is you
know extract the file then there's a
certain compression method that you want
to use called gzip be verbose right - be
tar is one of those awkward commands
where you don't have to specify - here
it's so even you know there's this UNIX
philosophy but there are lots of
commands you know like like find that
that don't really adhere to this so so
don't take it all too too seriously like
I said nice little website very useful
but of course we want to do this from
the command line right so let's let's
write one and this is it this is
another tool that I that I wrote just
showing you lots of tools that I wrote
but just to illustrate to you that it's
actually really easy to create something
that can be reused so let's go through
this again these are just some comments
well the first one again our shebang
so bash should execute this this is all
ignored because it's it starts with a
hash here what we do is we say the
variable command should be everything
that we that we specified as arguments
to our explain command
so you're basically storing you know
your command that you're giving so tar
xvz F all right to command this is a
variable that we can later reuse and
that's what we do here we have here a
URL with command this will be a
substitute of with the value that's
that's that command contains into a new
variable called URL just just to make
your code a little bit more readable but
it's not really necessary we could have
done it all using justice as dollar sign
at and we use curl again to download you
remember download the file from from the
internet and we pipe that to scrape
which again specifies a CSS selector and
then we use some set magic to extract
just well to basically remove the HTML
tags and what it gives you here I use it
from the command line here everything is
put your Qatar X TV is put into command
curl is being run you don't see it here
but this is the output and this is
exactly well almost exactly a I what I
don't do is I also don't extract the
file name as you may see here I don't
think I extract - we'll have to look at
that but what you see here
well nicely formatted but because the
creator of this website use
sensible HTML we were able to expect
extract that Oh actually we do so now we
again have a text version so it's it's
almost like man or - that's age right
but now we can use it from the command
line so command line tools can also be
created from existing codes existing
code your R or Python code what you have
to do is you have to be able to accept
accept standard input right everything
you have to be able to pipe something to
it if the right to standard output that
would be the screen by default standard
error it's that's where all the errors
are put on by a certain command parse
command-line arguments which is very
cumbersome but there is a solution for
that would be nice if you provide some
help so how would your command be used
and again with some grain of salt try to
take the UNIX philosophy to cancer make
try to make your tools small don't try
to reinvent the wheel over again so
here's just one example
it's Python code as you may recognize
but using a package called duck opt you
don't have to put a lot of work in
specifying your command-line arguments
you're just specified as it is this is
what you would expect if you would say -
H well help and we can specify
parameters here so - n it do not up with
a trail a new line and this command is
just it's a silly command it's I call it
Piko it's just created for this
presentation it's well it's like echo it
would echo whatever you give to it but
here you can see if we run pi quit at h
it gives you help so it is this nice to
the user's right it also returns to
version because that's what I've
specified right here
and it does what it what it tells you so
a few words about data science toolbar
box.org
this is a URL that now simply redirects
to a github repo but this github repo is
both a collection of command line tools
some of which i've shown you tonight
but it's also a vagrant environment
because what I haven't shown you tonight
is how cumbersome it can be to install
all these individual command line tools
they all have their own package managers
or they will use make and it's very
cumbersome so what I've done and a
couple of others as well and we're
working together actually to come up
with an even better environment what
we've done we've created an environment
a so called vagrant environment so that
you can get started within minutes
whether you're on Linux Mac OS or on
Windows right everybody is invited to
this party
what it does it runs on top of
VirtualBox so you have a virtual machine
running on your own laptop right there's
a whole separate machine and what it
does it installs all these tools for you
so that if you want to try this out
yourself you can well you just have to
issue two commands you don't have to
install everything yourself
question yes yes
yeah there is this tool yeah well with
Rio yes you could use Rio so the
question is can we also do this for our
and the answer is yes well there's Rio
but there was also something a little R
which you can use to make our part of
your pipeline so I have quite a few
things to talk about but since we you
know we have we had a couple of
questions and I really appreciate this I
think this is great but this does mean
that and I do I really do respect your
time so this does mean that I have to
well well that I would have to stop here
and jump to the conclusion so
parallelization well I really recommend
that you check out new parallel because
it allows you to parallelize existing
command line tools my apologies for just
going through this it allows you to to
really run existing tools on multiple
cores on multiple CPUs and on multiple
servers right from the command line
it's all in there you don't have to look
at packages in Armour and or you know or
or Python to make your program your code
well distributed or parallel lines
there's a lot of functionality for
resuming field jobs and and gathering
the output there so I can really
recommend that ok so just like I did for
parallel just a few words about workflow
management and then I'll give you my
conclusions so as you've seen working
with the command line can be very
chaotic right it's just a lot of
commands altogether and this is this is
because we invoke many different
commands right and we create custom
command line tools of our own and we
also have lots of different files to
work with so so it can be
can be tricky if you if you want to pick
up an existing project and a couple of
weeks or even pass it on to one of your
colleagues you know indeed the back-end
engineer that has to implement my my
hacks does not appreciate this so there
is a tool call Drake and Drake is like
make but then for data created by
factual and it allows you to formalize
the steps of your workflow right so
download the HTML extract certain
elements convert it to JSON and so forth
it allows it it allows you to to
formalize this in steps and the
dependencies between them and this has
the advantage that first of all your
entire workflow is is is well-defined it
also means that once you have when
certain steps have been executed like
downloading a very large file not just
HTML but what if it's if it's if it's a
terabyte from s3 if you have all your
steps in one script that mean you run
this script that means that all the
steps will be executed again so if you
have but if you have a workflow and
Drake Drake will recognize this and will
then just skip this step and move on to
steps that do need to be executed so
this is sort of what it looks like you
can use variables here so this arrow
here the term is like okay we have some
input here there is no input but the
output is top to the HTML we just
download this file this these are the
top ebooks from Project Gutenberg and we
piped it into output which is here so
you don't have to specify things more
than once and then there is a second
step which depends on top of the HTML so
Drake will recognize this and also will
generate an output file based on this
variable here so in here we by default
get the top 5 books from Project
Gutenberg but if we don't want to get
the top 10 we don't have to download the
H
mell again which is actually it's not a
big deal in this case but just imagine
that you have a very big file or a very
long process here we don't have to do
that again Drake will recognize this and
just execute everything as necessary so
it's under an active development
installing it is a bit tricky so I do
actually you just now have to go to the
home website and then check out how its
installed but in any case I can
recommend it so time for some
conclusions well thanks I was able now
to just finish the presentation albeit
with the last two sections a bit in a
hurry but we do have some really good
questions so I think that is that it's
worth something as well so I hope that I
have been able to convince you that at
the command line is definitely a great
environment for doing data science not
just you know obtaining scrubbing and
exploring but even modeling and then you
know interpreting data but I guess you
will have to wait for the book that I'm
writing to also hear about those other
two steps now I do want to mention again
that the command line does not solve all
your problems right it is it is okay to
to just use it for one or two things and
then continue with with our Python I
keep saying this but of course I also
include well any other programming
language which you like to use you can
even well perhaps from your programming
language run certain run command-line
tools so there are various ways in which
you can integrate the command line with
your existing toolbox so where to go
from here
well if you really want to try this out
then I can recommend first of all
installing the data science toolbox
because if you're if you're on Windows
you will be
with completely different terminals it's
it's something called the PowerShell and
I don't know anything about the
PowerShell that it's very different from
what I presented today and so so the
data science tool box allows you to get
up and running really fast
alternatively you could go on to Amazon
Web Services and just launch an instance
they have a free tier you can just you
know run a computer in the cloud for
quite some time until it will start to
cost anything and then I recommend you
to do a tutorial if you're completely
new to this right so I've only been able
to to to discuss the tools the
command-line tools that have to do with
with data with processing data so but
there's a whole lot more to this
practice practice your one-liners create
scripts and again if you do have
anything I need anything ranging from
questions comments critique stroopwafels
so or our scripts anything that you
would like to share or ask me you are
more than welcome so so like I mentioned
queue stats created by by Tony it's it's
in it's own github repo which is
completely fine but it does also get
installed when you install the data
science toolbox
so and I think that if we if we work
together on this then we can create
really a good data science toolbox and I
should mention again or include our own
Python again because that will also be
installed by the data science toolbox
great so these are some references I'll
leave them on here and I want to well
quickly say thank you very much here's
my email address if you have any
questions you can also of course contact
me on Twitter there's also my website
and then thank you very much for
everything
and then I'm not sure if we actually
have time left for questions yes I will
be at the bar okay great I see the first
one over there yes
so how much can you do with Windows
commands I I believe that you can do a
whole lot these days but it uses I
believe thought NAT now I really have
don't have shouldn't say too much
because I don't have any experience with
it but alright we here here's cygwin but
then again if you're gonna if you if
you're willing to install cygwin I can
you might as well just install a virtual
box and have a a complete Linux
environment yourself so okay any other
questions oh yes I see one over there
do I have I done any benchmarks when it
comes to performance or speed Bosch vs.
Python and honestly I have not but what
I do know I expect this to be in some
cases a little bit slower when compared
to for example doing everything and go
but what I do know is that this gets the
job done much faster and that's that's
why I think we as data scientists like
to do we like to get stuff done but then
again once you have your prototype and
you do need something in production it
may be worthwhile to implement this into
some other language thank you
so third question last one
okay so is there a way so apparently the
Python interpreter takes take some time
to start up and I'm not aware of any
solutions for Python I know that for
Java which takes even longer there's
something called trip which yes there
they have a lot of nice coffee analogies
right there
what trip does it it preserves an
instance of the JVM for you so that when
you want to run on a JVM when you want
to run something again it's there for
you to use and I'm not aware actually of
something for Python yeah all right
thank you very much